miss plana how are you how was your
weekend amazing fantastic that's all i'd
like to hear all right what do you got
for us first gold band
yeah so
leaders of g7 countries plan to announce
a ban on gold imports from russia the
latest the latest in a series of
sanctions the club hopes will further
hit russia's economy over its invasion
of ukraine so there's a couple of things
that i think is funny here if you put
the word gold ban
together
like if it was one word
and then you switch out the b with an m
then it spells gold men
that's not funny no it's funny because
this is exactly what goes on as all
these large institutions like goldman
and others are participating in this
whole gold market now one of the folks
uh that i was talking to over the
weekend uh danny over from cash happy
software engineer uh he had a really
interesting theory he said look the gold
bugs for years and years have been
predicting this idea that physical gold
the actual gold itself actually is
participating in a fractional reserve
system where many of these exchanges
have taken the gold and then they've
essentially levered it up so sometimes
there's as much as a hundred x the
number of paper claims on the actual
gold itself and so in a fractional
reserve system just like any traditional
bank if there's a run for people to get
the asset if all of a sudden people
start saying hey give me the gold give
me my gold give me my gold and there's
not enough physical gold
they can't give you the gold and so in
that scenario what would drive it is
that the price would be exploding
upwards people would want the gold and i
actually want cash so when the g7 comes
in and they ban the import of russian
gold by the way gold is gold it just
comes from russia it's not russian it's
gold from russia uh but when the gold is
not able to be imported from russia that
cuts off a certain portion and all of a
sudden people start to say man if i want
gold exposure am i just getting the
paper claims on the gold i'm actually
getting the gold itself and so it could
potentially there is no guarantee of it
it could potentially though start to
lead to people saying i want the
physical gold give me the physical gold
remember the uh viral video on the
internet from a couple years ago where
the gold at
you ever seen that video
no leprechaun up in them trees you never
seen it oh man
come on
i'm gonna get a backhoe and get up in
that tree that's where he said wear the
gold at okay that's what people are
asking right now where is the gold and
right now we're about to find out where
is the gold okay so that's why the band
is important cool
layoffs so that's cool not cool less
than six months ago all these wall
street banks were celebrating they were
on a hiring binge of all the ipos all
the things that were happening and now
now thanks to a confluence of factors
that have cast the poll over the markets
i don't know what that means um
broad-based job cuts loom for the first
time at banks since 2019.
wow
do we know if they're cutting just the
mortgage departments or if they're
cutting across the bank i think it's a
cross okay i saw some headlines last
week that people were laying off members
of their mortgage departments which
would make sense because if mortgage
rates are going up and less people are
taking mortgages that means that the
revenue of that specific department is
likely going down but also like not a
ton of companies are going to go public
so the people are so invested in banking
yes there's a whole bunch of things but
you just got to go sector by sector
within a bank and say who is being
affected the most those are likely to be
places where they're going to cut first
because they're trying to balance out
revenue with expenses it's just how you
get to profitability it just shows how
quickly things can change
in turn
uh there's a direct line between
monetary and fiscal policy that led to
an asset bubble that asset bubble then
led to high inflation uh that high
inflation led to the federal reserve
trying to talk tough and get tighter
financial conditions those tighter
financial conditions led to less revenue
in certain sectors for a bank which then
means that the bank preparing for a
potential downturn has to lay people off
now you can call that a straight line
you can call that a little squiggly line
but there is a line between federal
reserve policy and people getting jobs
or losing jobs in the real economy
including at banks and that's what we're
seeing right here is that if people are
scared about us going into some sort of
economic downturn then they cut jobs
that's what happens
yeah do you agree yes and speaking of
banks investment banks credit suisse
was convicted of failing to prevent
money laundering by a bulgarian of
course it's got to be a bulgarian a
bulgarian cocaine trafficker in the
first ever criminal conviction of a
major swiss lender in the country's
history so credit suisse i feel like
lately they've been just kind of not
able to just
i don't know they've they've been all
over the place why are you going after
the bulgarians i like the bulgarians not
not the drug traffickers
[Music]
so
oh it's a woman this is interesting wow
wow you thought it was a man
automatically why because he's doing bad
things yeah
yeah
all right so are you ready yeah one of
the pieces that's very interesting about
let's just
label it all as money laundering or
nefarious activities at banks is that
banks in many cases if they were
investigators like literally they were
law enforcement
an investigation could take months could
take years to actually come up with some
of this stuff and so there is a thought
process that a bank doesn't have to uh
go to the level of detail that a
financial investigator law enforcement
has to go to but they do have to do some
level of cursory uh due diligence in
order to be able to say what they
straight phase we do not believe that
this person is engaging in any nefarious
or illegal activity we think this is a
person that we want to do business with
now one of the things that has come out
of the 2008 financial crisis and many
other regulations that followed uh in
the ensuing years is that a lot of banks
what they would do is they would
continue to do business with groups that
depending on who you ask in the bank
they might say ah they're good but
they'd be like ah you know they we work
with all kinds of different people
everyone's on a spectrum and they would
kind of talk it away
and so when that happens uh what the
banks would do is they would just flag
tons and tons of transactions or tons
and tons of clients they would basically
flood the compliance departments or the
overseers yeah with all these flags and
then so if anything it later on came up
to be an issue they like well we flagged
it
well if you flag a lot and you're doing
it without actually trying to identify
the highest risk you're just flagging
anything
yes you are covering your butt but
are you actually going ahead and trying
to solve the problem probably not what's
interesting here is that they went after
the bank
every bank has engaged in this stuff
there's been the uh mexican cartels
there's been plenty of money laundering
like all these different things happen
but to actually convict the bank's
pretty big deal well i was right by the
way that credit suisse has been all over
the place because it says it has been
struggling with a series of scandals
that have sent its shares to near record
lows and it may face a second criminal
indictment in an unrelated case later
this year i so yes obviously that is
true that is a fact
but
i think a lot of the banks are going
through this we saw recently uh jp
morgan they got uh um fined uh for some
metal manipulations uh if i remember
correctly uh there's a couple of other
things that have happened where uh banks
are now being held accountable to some
degree but i think there's a lot of
folks who say look this is nothing like
there's so many more things that they
should be held accountable for and then
of course there are some folks who um
who continue to say to themselves
if you're the bank could you actually
figure this out like if somebody shows
up and says have a business uh my
business has x dollars in it and they
say what line of business are you in you
tell them you've never been convicted of
a crime before you've never been uh in
trouble before at what point is enough
of the diligence and i don't have that
answer that's why they're banks and i'm
not uh but you are in a suit but you're
not a bank yeah well if i was in the
bank and in a suit everyone would be in
trouble
but what i do think is important here is
to understand that uh you've got to ask
the bank are you just simply trying to
check all the boxes so you can continue
to do business get fees it's just a
really hard business
well or are you trying to solve the
problem
it's just a really hard problem to solve
i think that that's a very fair position
yes all right let's talk about open ai
why this one interesting so you know
open ai how they had gpt three and
people were like oh my god this like
machine can write sentences explain what
gbt3 is it's like a
machine learning
natural language processing
unit
product
i don't know
okay that was actually way better than
like 90 of people if you ask them they'd
be like oh it's artificial intelligence
well everyone was like freaking out
because gpt3 could like write articles
and finish sentences whatever now it has
a cousin called
dolly2
and it's a cousin trained on text and
images
and it's causing a similar stir online
when it began whipping up surreal images
of astronauts riding horses and more
recently it has learned to play
minecraft after watching 70 000 hours of
video showing people playing the game on
youtube this is wild cause minecraft is
a strategy game it's not like snake
snake yes and no
because when
when you try to understand how they're
doing this stuff
it's still machine learning like if a
human sat there and understood what was
happening and watched 70 000 hours of
minecraft on youtube right they likely
would be able to pick up patterns but a
human could never watch seventy thousand
hours of anything ah
okay except you
you know you just do you know what we
need on here we need our 11 year old
analyst jacob
he would have opinions on minecraft he
would say i've watched 75 000 hours on
youtube uh so in some way like that's
all the technology is doing is it's just
learning the patterns right hence the uh
machine learning and then what's unique
about this one is uh putting text and
images together so you can basically
just say you know create an image uh
what was the example like uh with
astronauts on horses
and then it understands astronauts
horses and like and it'll come up and
it'll basically create that image and so
when you start to break down how they do
this stuff it's not hard to understand
like what the theoretical uh kind of um
operation is
the hard part is actually making it do
it and that's what's so impressive about
it and the other impressive part is that
like you know when i place chess unlike
chess uh minecraft has any number of
possible objectives progress is less
linear and deep reinforcement learning
algorithms are usually left spinning
their wheels it's a strategy well i
guess stress is true but like it's more
it's less defined
and so really right i mean obviously
chess you can play the computer like
that was an original version and then
you kind of just go through uh and
they're gonna get less and less defined
and eventually uh the idea of artificial
intelligence is for it to be quite
intelligent will it be able to actually
think for itself and there's a lot of
folks like man that is amazing i can't
wait to do that i can't wait to have
that in our lives and there's a lot of
people like
have you met people like i don't know if
you necessarily want there to be
artificial intelligence that we have no
idea how to control let me tell you
about the next artificial intel
intelligence that will blow your mind um
amazon alexa the latest iteration could
sound eerily familiar they have figured
out how to make it sound like your
deceased loved ones so technically your
deceased grandmother could read you a
bedtime story
i got i got multiple problems with
elections hey honestly i'm not beef with
the letters what's your beef well when
we tell alexa be quiet do you remember
what she wouldn't stop she would just
play this like creepy song and you're
like stop alexis i've never i've never
had beef with a robot until one day i
forget what happens
uh yeah the roomba also robots in my
house i got beef with there's only two
robots in the house alexa and roomba
they both wait so they're not allowed to
be used when i'm around uh no it's like
if they don't listen it's frustrating
yeah so so alexa literally was playing
her song and we're like stop it we got
so desperate we had to unplug her i was
like all right guess what checkmate
checkmate alexa but what happens when
you can't unplug the robot and hold
another okay
wait wait can i say one thing yes um
this technology is definitely it's
already been here to some degree it
wasn't perfect but it is accelerating um
you probably uh remember a business stat
muse was the first time i ever saw the
technology
and what they essentially did um was
they went and they would do deals uh
with big sports stars they did have one
with dion sanders uh one peyton manning
etc and you could ask this app stat muse
musc you could ask it a question and
when you asked it a question you could
say um how many touchdowns did peyton
manning throw in the playoffs during his
career and when it would respond to you
peyton manning's voice would be the one
that would respond and peyton manning
would basically uh be able to read back
the answer but the way that they did
that is they would take your speech when
you asked the question they would turn
it into text that text would then be
analyzed once the text was analyzed they
would then go and get the answer
somewhere how a google would they would
pull the text-based answer and then they
would go text the speech back but
instead of it just being some robotic
voice they would actually have peyton
manning's voice do it and so when they
did it
it sounded just like peyton manning and
there was all this technology as to how
they blended together all the different
talking points and and made it sound
more human but you still could kind of
tell it was peyton but kind of sort of
sounded like a robot and it was getting
better
now they got it where it just sounds
like a real person that's crazy yeah
well imagine when uh i could send you a
voice note
but i didn't actually uh create the
voice note i just typed it and then it's
read to you but it's in my voice why
would i want that uh anthony siri is a
british woman
that's all i have today
what you want to say
listen she sounds more sophisticated
than the american uh robot voice
does she not she does she does yeah so
whenever i'm talking to uh uh siri i
just you know i'm like oh let me let me
get more serious for a second here
all right what are you gonna do hi
friends do you have anything that you
want to tell people before i let you go
um yeah i want to give a shout out to
somebody in the comments his name is
zach sg he's been so nice to me since
day one just throwing that out there
thank you i appreciate you zach how much
did you pay for that shout out
all right thank you very much appreciate
it hey you did you like this video great
we make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time